[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous
pensez-vous avoir encore le choix
alors je vous rassure j'attends pas que
chacun d'entre vous me donne une réponse
ce serait un petit peu long j'ai mon
idée concernant la réponse et je
souhaiterais la partager avec vous
aujourd'hui
alors personnellement j'ai une vie
plutôt simple je gagne pas des dizaines
de milliers d'euros par mois j'ai pas
trouvé de vaccins révolutionnaire
j'ai pas fait le tour du monde non plus
en revanche j'ai toujours choisi ma vie
ah oui certains certaines d'entre vous
ont peut-être remarqué la très bizarre
qui pointe derrière de mon crâne et vous
pouvez vous dire mais quelle force a
bien pu le pousser à faire ce choix de
coiffure
et bien tout simplement parce que j'en
avais envie ça me faisait plaisir et je
ne causais tort à personne
alors je vous cache pas que ma femme a
un avis un petit peu différent sur la
question et ça la démange de temps en
temps de mettre un grand coup de ciseaux
dedans toujours est-il que j'ai ce
pouvoir de décision et chacun d'entre
nous à ce pouvoir au quotidien
ces choix aussi futile soit-il en
apparence sont chaque instant de notre
vie
pourtant la société s'efforce de nous
faire croire que nous n'avons plus
réellement le choix
et pour être plus clair je vais vous
parler d'un cas concret que j'ai nommé
le choix de la baguette
lorsque vous trouvez dans une
boulangerie et que vient votre tour vous
est-il jamais arrivé de vous dire c'est
cette baguette là que je veux vous savez
vous envoyer une qui a un peu plus
croustillante un peu plus blanche enfin
elle est à votre goût et vous espérez
qu'on va vous la donner et vous ne dites
rien
avec un peu de chance vous obtenez l'élu
sinon vous repartez qu'une très légère
déception rien de bien grave déception
quand même
alors dites-moi qu'est-ce qui nous
empêche de demander cette baguette
ça va prendre quelques secondes de plus
on va causer de tort à personne et puis
nous payons cette baguette il est
légitime de pouvoir la choisir
mais non nous laissons quelqu'un d'autre
choisir à notre place
et ce concept du choix de la baguette
peut s'appliquer à de nombreux domaines
de notre vie
demander une table près de la fenêtre
dans un restaurant
se teindre les cheveux en bleu
refuser de se rendre à une cousinade ou
n'importe quel repas de famille mais je
suis à peu près sûr que vous voyez de
quoi je parle
dans ma jeunesse comme beaucoup d'entre
vous j'en suis sûr on m'a dicté mes
choix
visiblement tout le monde savait plus ou
moins ce que je devais faire de ma vie
en l'occurrence me concernant c'était
rien
je me souviens avoir entendu très
souvent mais qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de
Romain alors on aurait pu me consulter
un peu plus pour commencer alors je n'en
veux à personne en toute sincérité c'est
ainsi dès notre plus jeune âge la
société nous habitue au concept que nous
n'avons pas réellement le choix
c'est plus simple pour tout le monde ou
du moins pour ceux qui eux veulent
choisir pour les autres
alors très vite j'ai compris que je ne
laisserai personne décider à ma place je
choisirais ma vie
et c'est ce qui m'a mené sans diplôme à
gérer des opérations de sauvetage en mer
publier 15 romans ou diriger une agence
de communication
et tout ça en cassant la boucle des
croyances
casser la boucle des croyances alors le
terme un petit peu barbare comme ça donc
je vais être un peu plus clair par
exemple je pense que tout le monde peut
écrire un roman
attention je dis pas que tout le monde
peut écrire un bon roman et le publier
chez un éditeur je dis que tout le monde
est capable d'apprendre à écrire un
roman
je crois pas vraiment en cette grâce
divine qui guide la plume des romanciers
ou les Muses ou tous ces concepts un peu
élitiste qui vise à sacraliser les
autres auteurs
dans ma jeunesse
j'étais pas un élévation j'étais au
lycée de keraoul pour ceux qui
connaissent c'est à Paimpol pas très
loin d'ici et je me souviens que mon mon
cousin me rapportait que ma professeur
de français se moquait de moi auprès des
autres classes elle parlait de mes
mauvais résultats des erreurs que je
faisais donc il va y avoir une espèce de
d'objectif pédagogique un peu obscur
quand même quoi mais toujours est-il que
en effet je n'aimais pas l'école je ne
travaillais pas
j'avais de mauvais résultats donc c'est
assez concret j'ai pris dans cette
boucle de mauvais élèves
ainsi qu'en quelques années plus tard
j'ai partagé l'idée de d'écrire un roman
les préjugés ont envie de prier le pas
et le verdict fut sans appel romain tu
n'y arriveras pas
ma scolarité ne me permettait pas ce
choix
alors je suis breton donc je suis têtu
donc j'ai quand même décidé de tenter
l'aventure parce qu'encore une fois je
faisais de mal à personne
pas même à moi-même j'ai voulu tenter ça
m'a demandé beaucoup d'efforts
évidemment j'avais un peu de retard à
rattraper mais lorsque mon premier roman
fut publié
les réactions
quand même c'est légitime
joie jalousie personnellement je n'en ai
retenu qu'une seule chose j'avais
inconsciemment cassé la boucle des
croyances mais mauvais résultats
scolaires n'étaient pas une fatalité
auparavant j'étais pris dans dans cette
dans cette boucle de mauvais élève du
coup je ne travaillais pas j'avais des
mauvais résultats espèce de spirale de
la loose un petit peu quoi où je me gamê
à chaque fois et quand j'ai publié ce
roman en fait c'est quand j'ai fini
d'écrire ce roman parce que finalement
le fait qu'il soit publié par un éditeur
c'était la cerise sur le gâteau mais
c'est surtout le fait d'avoir réussi à
l'écrire d'avoir acheté quelque chose je
me suis rendu compte que j'étais pas un
bon à rien
et d'un coup ma vision de la vie a
changé
j'ai réalisé qu'il était crucial
voir même vital d'abattre les barrières
qui nous dit que ce que nous pouvons ou
ne pouvons pas faire
il y a tant de choses en fait qui sont
possibles dans la vie on peut très bien
être petit et jouer au basket
avoir 14 ans faire du tricot ou de la
couture
décider de commencer un sport ou tomber
amoureux à 70 ans
vous allez me dire on choisit pas de
tomber amoureux et oui ça je pense que
c'est vrai aussi par contre on peut
choisir de se mettre des barrières pour
ne pas tomber amoureux
ainsi tous ces événements dépendent des
choix que nous faisons
alors parfois il est plus simple de
laisser d'autres faire les choix à notre
place là-dessus je le fais également ça
nous demande moins d'efforts et puis
nous nous sommes
confortés parfois inconsciemment dans
l'idée que nous n'avions plus réellement
le choix mais c'est faux
en fait il faut penser à ce qu'on
appelle notre écologie ce qui est bon
pour nous et notre entourage
et faire un choix c'est aussi savoir
dire non
enfin nous savons très bien dire non il
y a des parents dans la salle je pense
qu'il voit très bien de quoi je parle
pourtant la vie nous fait perdre peu à
peu cette faculté innée
ainsi faire un choix c'est parfois
refuser certaines contraintes quand rien
ne nous oblige à les accepter
dans une précédente carrière j'ai refusé
une promotion on proposait plus d'argent
plus davantage enfin tout ce qui va avec
une promotion
le choix était très simple pour moi j'ai
refusé cette promotion toute ma
hiérarchie m'a immédiatement convoquée
personne n'acceptait ma décision on m'a
expliqué que ce type de promotion ne se
refusait pas que personne ne faisait ça
gérer torqué comme l'a proposé donc
j'étais libre de dire oui ou non
ça c'est simple comme concept pourtant
mais bon
toujours est-il que pourquoi j'ai refusé
cette promotion mais en fait j'ai pensé
à ce qui était bon pour moi et ma
famille
je ne cherchais pas l'argent ou la
gloire mais le bien-être et l'équilibre
et je sais pertinemment que je n'aurais
pas eu avec cette promotion
ainsi faire un choix
c'est parfois refuser nous avons le
droit de refuser
et si cela ne cause de tort à personne
il n'est pas nécessaire de nous
justifier cette notion là aussi est très
importante
la société nous incitent à suivre le
mouvement et à prendre le moins de
décision possible
ainsi lorsqu'on fait un choix qui sort
de l'ordinaire on peut se sentir obligé
de se justifier
apprendre un petit cas concret
imagineriez-vous un seul instant vous
rendre dans un magasin de chaussures
passer la porte d'entrée rester sur
l'espèce de grand paillasson
rectangulaire qui à chaque fois et
demander à la vendeuse d'aller vous
chercher une paire à votre taille
qu'elle choisira elle-même
elle vous ramène le modèle qu'elle
souhaite vous payez vous partez on est
d'accord que c'est complètement aberrant
personne ne ferait ça on veut choisir
nos chaussures
pourtant dans d'autres circonstances
souvent plus fréquentes et tout aussi
importante justement parce qu'elles sont
plus fréquentes nous laissons d'autres
prendre les décisions à notre place
ainsi lorsqu'on fait ce choix inhabituel
on peut se sentir obligé de se justifier
vous est-il jamais arrivé au restaurant
de ne pas prendre de dessert et de vous
sentir obligé de vous justifier auprès
du serveur
vous savez quand il vous apporte la
carte des desserts avec un grand sourire
vous vous en voulez pas pour les raisons
qui vous incomplent mais plutôt que de
dire NON MERCI ah non merci le repas
était très copieux c'était très bon on
est un peu pressé tout un tas de choses
en fait comme si on s'excusait parce
qu'un repas se termine par un dessert
dans les conventions
du coup on se sent obligé de justifier
ce choix
mais justifier un tel choix c'est comme
admettre une mauvaise décision ou une
erreur
ainsi pour de plus subir les événements
de la vie en permanence je vous propose
de garder à l'esprit trois points
cruciaux
quels sont la boucle des croyances
ne faisons pas les choses uniquement
parce que tout le monde fait ainsi il y
a parfois d'autres possibilités
osons dire non
quel que soit la situation je suis
convaincu si nous le souhaitons qu'il
est toujours possible de refuser
et enfin ne nous justifions pas en
permanence nos choix n'appartiennent
qu'à nous
quand vous sortirez de cette salle tout
à l'heure
votre chez vous serez dans la voiture ou
dans quelques jours vous êtes tranquille
je vous invite à apprendre un petit
moment et vous demander s'il n'y a pas
certaines choses que vous souhaiteriez
faire vous avez toujours voulu faire
mais que vous écartez naturellement
parce que la société votre entourage ou
tout autre raison ou faire croire que
vous ne pouvez pas le faire que ce choix
ne vous appartient pas ou qui ne vous
appartient plus
la vie n'est qu'une succession de choix
et si nous les faisions nous-mêmes merci
de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]